♪ ♪
>> Trey: NEW INFORMATION ON
THE SCOPE OF THE DURHAM PROBE,
SOURCES TELLING FOX NEWS SPECIAL
JOHN DURHAM IS DONE
INVESTIGATING THE CIS ROLE IN
THE ORIGINS OF THE RUSH OF
PROBE.
DURHAM HAS A REPORT OF THE MOVED
TO THE FBI BUT ALSO SAYING IT IS
UNLIKELY THAT HIGH-RANKING
OFFICIALS LIKE JIM COMEY WILL BE
CHARGED.
FOR JOINING ME NOW, FORMER
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE UNITED STATES
CONGRESSMAN, FORMER U.S.
ATTORNEY JOHN RATCLIFFE.
JOHN, HOW ARE YOU?
>> TREY, GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Trey: I WANT TO BEGIN BY
TAKING A LOOK AT JIM COMEY BACK
IN 2018.
LISTEN TO THIS AND GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> TOTAL CONFIDENCE THAT THE
FISA PROCESS WAS FOLLOWED AND
THE ENTIRE CASE WAS HANDLED IN A
THOUGHTFUL AND RESPONSIBLE WAY
BY DOJ AND FBI.
I THINK THE NOTION THAT FISA WAS
ABUSED HERE IS NONSENSE.
>> Trey: NONSENSE?
I THINK YOU ARE ONE OF THE
REPUBLICAN ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THAT WALL ASKING HIM QUESTIONS.
LET ME FIRST ASK YOU, DO YOU
EXPECT MORE INDICTMENTS FROM THE
DURHAM PROBE?
>> I THINK THE INTELLIGENCE THAT
I HAVE SEEN WOULD REFLECT THAT
THERE WOULD BE ADDITIONAL
ACTIONS TAKEN BY JOHN DURHAM.
YOU KNOW, THAT CLIP THAT YOU
PLAYED THERE, TREY, I REMEMBER
IT WELL.
YOU AND I DID ASK A LOT OF
QUESTIONS BECAUSE WE WERE
CONVINCED THAT THERE WAS FISA
ABUSE, AND WE WERE UNFORTUNATELY
RIGHT, AND JIM COMEY HAD TO WALK
THAT BACK, AND WE SAW THE LAWYER
THAT CREATED THOSE FALSE
APPLICATIONS PLEAD GUILTY THIS
WEEK, AND IT IS FOR THAT SAME
REASON THAT WHEN I BECAME DNI
AND I SAW MORE INTELLIGENCE, I
BECAME MORE CONVINCED THAT THERE
WAS MORE INCIDENTS LIKE THAT AS
IT RELATED TO THE 2016 CAMPAIGN.
WITHOUT BETRAYING ANY
CONFIDENCE, I CAN TELL YOU I SAT
IN A ROOM LAST JULY WITH DON
DURHAM, ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR, A
ALL UNANIMOUSLY AGREED THERE
WAS A PROBLEM WITH RESPECT TO
THE FBI, THAT THERE WAS NOT A
PROPER PREDICATE TO BEGIN MUCH
LESS CONTINUE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, SO I WOULD BE
SURPRISED IF THIS REPORTING IS
ACCURATE, THAT AREN’T GOING TO
BE ADDITIONAL INDICTMENTS.
I WOULD EXPECT THAT.
I THINK THE INTELLIGENCE THAT I
HAVE SEEN REFLECTS THAT.
AND I CERTAINLY THINK, YOU KNOW,
ONCE THE INVESTIGATION RUNS ITS
COURSE, THAT THAT IS WHAT WILL
TAKE PLACE.
>> Trey: YOU KNOW, JOHNNY, I
WAS STRUCK WITH A DICHOTOMY.
YOU CRY JIM COMEY OUT THERE
SAYING WHAT YOU AND OTHER HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WERE DOING LOOKING
INTO FISA ABUSE WAS NONSENSE.
AND YOU HAVE THE SYCOPHANT DISH
MOB OF REPORTERS.
I WONDER IF HE CHANGED HIS MIND
AT ALL SINCE NOW MORE FBI
EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN TO PRISON
THEN MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP FAMILY
FAMILY.
>> I DON’T KNOW.
I HOPE FOR THIS INVESTIGATION
GOES IS THAT THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL FOLKS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, NOT BECAUSE I WANT
TO SEE FOLKS GO TO PRISON BUT
BECAUSE I WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE
FAITH AND TRUST IN THE FBI AND
AFFIRMATIVE JUSTICE AND,
INCREASINGLY THEY DON’T.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE SEEN
THE TEXT MESSAGES AND EMAILS AND
MEMOS AND TRANSCRIPTS, AND FISA
APPLICATIONS, AND THEY KNOW THIS
JUST ISN’T RIGHT.
YOU TALKED EARLIER ABOUT
FAIRNESS, AND THEY SEE THAT THIS
JUST WASN’T FAIR, AND IF THE FBI
AND AFFIRMATIVE JUSTICE CAN’T
HOLD FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT,
THAN WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
PROBLEM DOWN THE ROAD.
>> Trey: JOHN, I WANT TO
SWITCH TO ANOTHER SUBJECT.
YOU ARE ALSO DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE CRITICIZED YOU
FOR YOUR FOCUS ON CHINA.
IT SEEMS LIKE MAYBE YOU WOUND UP
BEING RIGHT.
>> WELL, I INCREASED SPENDING ON
CHINA BY 20% BECAUSE CHINA IS
OUR GREATEST NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT, AND I THINK
INCREASINGLY, YOU KNOW, YOU ARE
SEEING SOME OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS TALK
ABOUT THE THREAT THAT CHINA IS
BECOMING.
AND MY POINT IS THIS.
CAN WE ALL JUST BE HONEST ABOUT
CHINA?
CAN WE NOT TREAT INTELLIGENCE ON
CHINA THE SAME WAY WE WOULD
TREAT INTELLIGENCE ON RUSSIA?
TAKE THIS, FOR EXAMPLE.
IF WE HAD INTELLIGENCE, CLEAR
INTELLIGENCE, THAT SAID THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN ORDERED
SCIENTISTS IN ST. PETERSBURG TO
EXPERIMENT ON CORONAVIRUS IS AT
THE ST. PETERSBURG INSTITUTE OF
VIROLOGY, AND THERE WAS A
PROBLEM WHEN PEOPLE STARTED
GETTING SICK AND PUTIN ORDERED
ST. PETERSBURG BE SET OFF FROM
THE REST OF RUSSIA BUT OPEN TO
THE REST OF THE WORLD AND HE
SILENCED SCIENTISTS AND DOCTORS
AND REPORTERS THAT WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT IT, AND HE LIVES TO
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT, 400,000
AMERICANS DIED AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF THAT VIRUS.
WHEN YOU THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND DEMOCRATS AND
THE MEDIA WOULD BE SAYING ABOUT
RUSSIA?
LET’S BE HONEST, BECAUSE THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT THE INTELLIGENCE
SHOWS US CHINA DID IN THIS CASE,
AND IT IS WHY CHINA IS OUR
GREATEST NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT AND WHY WE HAVE TO BE
CLEAR EYED ABOUT IT GOING
FORWARD.
>> Trey: WELL, JOHNNY, I DON’T
HAVE TO WONDER WHAT ONE HOUSE
DEMOCRAT WOULD SAY ABOUT THAT,
BECAUSE HE SAID THAT YOU WERE
KIND OF FALSELY EQUATING CHINA
WITH RUSSIA.
I THINK IT WAS AN OLD COLLEAGUE
OF YOUR NAME ERIC SWALWELL.
WE HAVE A CLIP IF YOU WANT TO
LISTEN TO IT AGAIN, BRINGS BACK
GOOD MEMORIES.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION PUT OUT A
STATEMENT THAT YOU HAVE CHINA
AND RUSSIA AND IRAN ALL
INTERFERING AND GAVE THIS FALSE
EQUIVALENCE TO THEM.
WHAT IS ACCURATE IN THE
STATEMENT THAT WAS PUT OUT TODAY
AS RUSSIA CONTINUES TO INTERFERE
IN OUR ELECTIONS.
THE WAY THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROCEEDING, IS TO JUST SAY,
"WELL, EVERYONE IS INTERFERING."
>> Trey: WELL, I THOUGHT IT
SHOWED A GOOD BIT OF WHEN
CONGRESSMAN SWALLOW WAS
CRITICIZING ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I
KNEW THE PUBLIC DID NOT KNOW AT
THAT POINT IN TIME ABOUT, YOU KN
RELATIONSHIP --
>> Trey: YOU DON’T HAVE TO
SHOW RESTRAINT NOW, JUST BE
YOURSELF.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO SHOW RESTRAINT
ANYMORE, JUST BE YOURSELF.
>> WHAT IS IMPORTANT IS THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY BE HONEST
ABOUT CHINA, AND THAT PEOPLE
STOP TRYING TO POLITICIZE
INTELLIGENCE TO MAKE CHINA LESS
OF A THREAT OR RUSSIA OR MORE OF
A THREAT.
LET THE INTELLIGENCE SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF, AND IF IT DOES, REALIZE
THAT CHINA AND CHINA ALONE IS
THE GREATEST NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT, THE ONE COUNTRY THAT CAN
SUPPLANT THE UNITED STATES IS A
WORLD SUPERPOWER, AND I WANT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO BE
HONEST ABOUT THAT BECAUSE IF
THEY DON’T RECOGNIZE THAT, WE
ARE ALL GOING TO SUFFER.
SO HOPEFULLY EVERYONE WILL NOT
JUST AGREED THAT I WAS RIGHT
ABOUT CHINA, BUT THAT WILL BE
HONEST ABOUT CHINA GOING FORWARD
FORWARD.
>> Trey: JOHNNY, WE’VE GOT
ABOUT 30 SECONDS.
TOUGH QUESTION.
GIVE ME A QUICK ANSWER.
FROM YOUR TIME AS THE DNI, WHAT
SCARES YOU THE MOST?
WHAT DO YOU KNOW NOW THAT YOU
DID NOT KNOW THE DAY BEFORE YOU
TOOK THE JOB?
AND KEEPS YOU AWAKE AT NIGHT?
>> WELL, I THINK THE THREE
GREATEST THREATS WE FACE, I
TALKED ABOUT CHINA, THAT’S MY
INCREASED SPENDING BY 20%.
CYBERSECURITY IS THE OTHER GREAT
THREATS.
WITH A GREAT EQUALIZER.
COUNTRIES LIKE CHINA OR RUSSIA
OR NORTH KOREA OR IRAN CAN’T
COMPETE WITH US CAN COMPETE AND
CAUSE US DAMAGE FROM HALF A
WORLD AWAY, A FEW SECONDS AND A